[Music]
good evening and welcome to this special
Q&A focused on good teaching I'm Tony
Jones here to answer your questions
teacher turned a champion of the Finnish
education system Parsis Albert Center
for independent studies Education
Research Fellow Jennifer Buckingham
primary school teacher Gabi Stroud who
quit the profession she loved in
frustration award-winning classroom and
youtube math teacher Eddie wood and
indigenous teacher and advocate Cindy
Berwick please welcome our
very much now Q&A is live in eastern
Australia on ABC TV iView and news radio
well tonight with year 12 final exams in
sight we've gathered a stellar panel and
an audience full of eager students
parents and teachers to talk about
better schools and our first question
comes from Miriam Lee's hey good evening
um it's not okay to say I can't read but
it's okay to say I can't do maths why do
you think that's the case
Eddie start with you obviously as
mathematics teacher having heard this
statement many many times I feel as
though there's a sense of frustration
boiling in my mind because I struggle
with mathematics when I was at school
and so today I was a math genius when
you're in school no and I'm still no
math genius now but for me that always
felt a little bit like an excuse and
then I realised I think Marian that in
many ways there was a sense of wanting
to have a reason wanting to have a
almost non excuse but a reason to say
look this is something that I've
struggled with mathematics is hard
mathematics is abstract it is you know
for the last 300 years or the
mathematics that we've invented as human
beings have been things that regular
people on the street have found
mind-blowing and so we want a reason to
be able to say yeah that was too hard
for me and I think the reason that we
grabbed for is it's just not my thing
it was genetics it was society and so I
think it's almost as though we're
looking for something to comfort us to
say this is difficult there was a reason
why it didn't have to do with me now
Eddie it wasn't my thing either as it
turns out even though my dad was a math
teacher but I do remember from school
the square on the hypotenuse equals the
sum of the squares on the other two
sides and I didn't really understand it
until I saw your woo tube
version of this now how is it that you
can explain things that many other
people struggle with well in fact I
think struggle actually is the key
because at school the humanities English
history and drama where the subjects
that I enjoyed most attorney despite the
fact that your dad wrote some of the
textbooks
jonesin catchment if anyone appreciates
that that code in mathematics it was a
classy classy work but that struggle
that I experienced as a student I still
carry with me now after more than ten
years of teaching and so I can actually
look at a student and the look in their
eyes and I can say
I know what that feels like and I think
that empathy is the key ingredient of
great teacher you would have seen that
look in my eyes many times if I be in
your math classes not to worry about
that Cindy Berwick now you were a maths
teacher for 20 years I was so why do you
think it is people say it's okay to say
I can't do maths what do you think well
I guess unlike Eddy I was actually I
actually enjoyed maths and it's been was
probably because I didn't like literacy
and I hated reading so you know I think
in those days you there was no such
thing as literacy and mathematics so I
think I gravitated towards maths because
there was nothing to do with reading
about it so I actually really enjoyed
maths and I actually enjoyed imparting
my knowledge to two young students and
opening their mind and I guess for me
it's about how you teach it you know and
then you've got a special way of doing
that haven't you particularly with young
indigenous kids out on stem cabs can you
tell us what that yeah we actually look
at you know mathematics and science and
technology through our cultural lens and
so we actually teach aerodynamics
through the boomerang and because the
boomerang actually led to the invention
of propellers which then led to flight
which then led to you know the invention
of drones which now patrol our
coastlines and save us from sharks and
and used in fire and rescue so there's a
lot of things that we do in our camps
that's relate to we teach chemistry
through the toxins in plants that that
our ancestors used to to eat we teach
throwing a boomerang there's a if
there's one a returning boomerang if you
want a boomerang that's returning you
need to throw it at a certain angle so
yeah there's all there's actually a lot
of mathematics in in everything that we
do and it's very and we try and related
to culture which then you know it sparks
the interest of Aboriginal kids now
parsley I only realised this evening
that you started as a mathematics
teacher as well and of course part of
the finished model is to is to have fun
as part of your education were you able
to do that with mathematics we've just
heard how these guys do it
how about Finland and how about your own
methods no myself I I didn't I didn't
know how to make mathematics fun but you
know one thing I realized that this
course by
to the the question earlier is that the
young people and probably many parents
as well have a very peculiar images of
what mathematicians do when they are in
work and so when I was a young math
teacher I carried out this research that
ended up being a larger research later
on simply asking my students pupils in
in the middle school that what do you
see what are you imagined when you think
about mathematician at work and guess
what they saw they always saw a male
unstylish
fat unmarried and somebody who has no
other friends but other mathematicians
so I think that you know the one one
reason why so easy to say that you know
reading is cute and many other things
are important but math is not because
most people don't really understand what
mathematicians do what they are like you
know for most of us the only things that
math people do is that they teach math
mathematics at the university to those
who go in to teach mathematics at school
and that's it so we have to change that
we have to help young people and parents
as well to understand that mathematics
is much more than just what you see in
school yeah well any you should respond
to that because you're not you're not in
tight ball and you have no make
mathematics cool well I think posi
strikes on something in that there's a
real lack of understanding about what
mathematics is in the you know there's a
sense that it's not numbers it's about
numbers and equations and solving
problems are given to an answer the
elusive thing at the back of the book
and of course numbers are a huge part of
mathematics but that's because
mathematics is a study of patterns and
relationships and connections there are
lots of those in numbers but there are
lots of those in lots of other spaces
which is why a lot of those people who
feel like I don't do maths but I will
talk about the statistics of my favorite
team until the cows come home I will be
able to calculate change I will be able
to know exactly when is the right time
to take my foot off the brake so I can
hit the green all of that is pattern
sensing which is mathematical well we
have just a bit of information here
about our audience because we asked
tonight's studio what is tell us their
favorite subject 24% said English 15%
his Street maths I'm afraid was a
distant third with 13 sad to hear that
Eddie I daresay I'm unsurprised but
that's what I'm working on yeah
right it is - let's go to another
question on mathematics from Fiona Foley
hi Tony what are your thoughts for the
panel on making mathematics mandatory in
years 11 and 12 considering the current
focus on stem technology for future
education demands and employment so that
was Jennifer what do you think it's very
difficult to make something compulsory
in year 11 and 12 if children are
struggling with it in the earlier years
of school and I think that's where we
need to start is making sure that maths
is being taught really well so we don't
get to that point where that Miriam
talked about where children lose
confidence and where they start to
believe they're just not good at at
maths and one of the difficulties with
masses that's so sequential and if you
miss some steps along the way it's very
difficult to recover and it's very easy
to lose confidence so I think that's
probably the first priority is making
sure that all children are up to the
standard of being able to study in
that's in your 11 and 12
yeah B what do you think yes I'd agree
with that look I think that you know
when we start talking about making
things mandatory and you know what's got
to happen as students approach the end
of school we need to be thinking about
the future that we're preparing them for
and the jobs that they're going to go
into but I really think - when we're at
the end of school we don't necessarily
know what we're going to do with the
rest of our lives you know went 17 and
18 we're still figuring a whole bunch of
stuff out so you know I think this idea
of making it mandatory if it's not your
passion and if it's something that you
know like you were just saying if you've
missed the sequence if you've struggled
with it you know if we're just going to
be flogging dead horses there then maybe
that's not maybe that's not the right
thing to do I just think that you're 11
and 12 you know they're formative years
but they're not the decisive years
they're not determining everything
that's going to happen for the rest of
your life so you know just because we
graduate school doesn't mean that we're
finished learning you know if you later
on like Eddy discovered this passion for
maths you can go ahead and you can
explore that then can I see
well sure no Jessica I just want to add
one thing I think that there's an
exception if people want to study a
degree in university that requires a
high level of math so engineering for
example so prerequisites for studying
certain courses in university makes
sense that they'd be at least a high
level of maths at the end of school yeah
but that means they have to figure it
out while they're at school what they
want to do later so Parsi how do you
handle this in Finland because you've
got a very strong reputation for STEM
subjects and I'm wondering is it
mandatory to keep studying maths and
possibly science all the way through
school I I think it's only the key
question here is what are we thinking
about when we ask this question of
mathematics in high school I think every
schools it should be mandatory that
every school will offer students math
courses that are something different
that they have done before
for example focusing on things that they
can use in their real life like like
economics or statistics or something
like this I think too often we think
about kind of a traditional way of
teaching mathematics as it's always been
in a school I think mathematics is very
important for everybody but not
necessarily the mathematics that we are
now teaching and making compulsory for
everybody Cindy what do you think
indigenous kids would obviously benefit
by being able to go on and do stem
courses should it be compulsory well I
think personally I think it should be
compulsory for all students because I
think the world revolves around
mathematics there's actually I think
we're you know there's there's crease
but there's a mathematics in everyday
life you know like Eddy said about
breaking of cars fixing cars going to
the shops buying things financial
numeracy there's a whole lot of things
that you use in everyday life I actually
taught a kid once who who who struggled
with volumes and surface areas and he
came back a year after and said I now
know why you taught me that he said I'm
a gas fitter and if I don't get the
volume right I'm gonna blow up everybody
go after myself I'm glad I teacher that
saves life but you know I think kids
have got to see the relevance you know
of it and and what they can use and I
don't think you know there's there's
relevance in everyday life and I think
one of the things we're actually in
trying to it at one of the school or one
of my schools we tried to get kids
interested in mathematics and we looked
at the or the university options and
there's not that many of universities
first-year courses they don't have a
maths element to it the architecture you
know all the visual arts like they all
have a mathematics part to it medicine
obviously medicine you know everything
and I think you know it's about how you
teach it the relevance of how they're
doing it and they need to be exposed to
to you know other forms of mathematics
that they may consider as Crees furthers
down the track but if the basic is about
living life with a certain skill set
yeah Eddie what do you think because I
mean you went on and became a real math
whiz when you were 19 so you'd left
school but you must have to keep that
sequential knowledge up you must have
studied all the way through school
so should it be mandatory because you
would have had that option otherwise
well I I want especially as a
mathematics teacher I want as many
children as possible to study
mathematics I love them all too but two
things I mean I would want them to
choose mathematics because they see its
value they see its it's important to
daily life and they want to let it they
have it appreciation so they choose it
and secondly I think it's really
important to mention and I guess I the
person in the classroom seeing it we
don't have enough mathematics teachers
as it is that's the reason why fifteen
years ago I went down this part instead
of becoming English history teacher if
we added another six thousand year 11
and 12 students we'd be in some serious
dire straits and so there's a lot of
groundwork that needs to be laid before
anything like that can be considered 10
to 15 years planning minimum okay let's
move on because got a lot of questions
tonight our next one comes from Alyssa
Millie hi as a current you 12 student
I've come to expect see my peers Bali in
the common room many of my classmates
peer disgruntle stress depressed and the
standard response to how are you is
tired and at while my friends schools
there's a really alarming number of
girls on antidepressants already at 17
or 18 and beyond all the stress there's
an overwhelming sense of boredom as we
write the same essays on the same text
again and again and again for about a
whole year and you feel like you're in
Groundhog Day and you feel trapped and
like you're actually being hindered from
learning opposed to being helped and you
can very easily become very apathetic
very resentful very frustrated is there
a better way than this
Gabby I'll start with you and with with
the HSC coming up and other exams
throughout the country there must be a
lot of young people feeling like exactly
like this at the moment yeah absolutely
there's tons of them and they're not
just in year 12 I think we're seeing a
time where education in Australia we
jeepers we must be getting close to
rock-bottom because I think there are
teachers that are suffering there are
students that are suffering and what
you're saying Alyssa is just exactly
that you and I just want to say I am so
sorry I'm sorry that you and your peers
feel like that because that's not what
it's meant to be like that's not what
it's meant to feel like and I think that
what you're describing this I loved that
description and your question just gives
me hope you know you kids are succeeding
in spite of the system not because of it
and your question just gives me hope and
I love that expression you know this
same essay that I'm churning out all
year long I think actually what you're
speaking about is the effects of
standardization that we're feeling
completely across the board from
kindergarten because I've taught
kindergarten kids that well I mean they
didn't feel it in my class but you know
you know we see these effects you know
right through till year 11 in when you
talk about Saturday's testing aren't you
I'm talking about standardized testing
I'm talking about a standardized
curriculum I'm talking about
professional teaching standards and it's
this blanket one size fits all let's
just churn it out and you know sprinkle
out the education on all these kids and
presumably you know they'll all come out
the other end and you know things will
all be fine and we'll collect a whole
bunch of data on it and the graphs will
go up and you know I'm here to tell you
they're not they're not the graphs are
going down the students are disengaged
the teachers are struggling and
something needs to change
let's hear from Jennifer because I think
you actually you believe that testing is
vital is it is there a better way as
what our questioner is asking than the
constant pursuit of the higher eighth
are in the HSC and the standardized
testing that leads up to that over many
years well this is testing in this
testing that the HSC it's a very
stressful experience and because it is
high-stakes there's a lot that hinges on
and all that students at least feel
hinges on them getting Aneta that
enables them to do what they want to do
which is interesting in a way because
there are more alternative routes into
University now than there ever was you
know when I did the HSC it was TIA or
bust you know there weren't any other
ways that you know really you could get
into a university course so that world
has opened up a little bit it with
respect to NAPLAN though I think that
that's quite a different question
NAPLAN doesn't have the sort of stakes
attached to it for the student
particularly you know what we're going
to adapt learn in more detail in a
little while stick just for a moment -
is there a better way than the HSC with
all this stress laid on many students
across the country not only the HSC of
course but the other versions of that in
different states yeah they may well be
instant states do different things and
and look if students are feeling as
though they're writing the same essay
multiple times all throughout the year
then then that shouldn't
be the case that shouldn't be the way
that you achieve a high score oh that
you show what you've learned so there
must be a better wave that if that's the
way that you're being taught I see what
do you think
I mean you've here you here been here
long enough to kind of work out how we
do it in New South Wales and other
states what do you think about that and
what do you think about the stresses
these HSC students in New South Wales
are facing now and in other states and
their different exams yeah I think this
is it first of all this is a very
important question and you know if I if
I compare that to what is happening to
people like you in many other countries
certainly in my own old country Finland
is that Australia has the highest
compulsory instruction I was required
from your children throughout their
compulsory education than any other
country in the world let alone Finland
so it means that you already have a kind
of a packed school II as full of
instruction and school days are much
longer than elsewhere that's why you
have much less time for play and many
other things and recess and and those
things that make your school day lighter
and I'm more comfortable and that's a
big difference if you compare Australia
to almost any other country in the world
certainly certainly Finland that the
students all the way up to the 12th
grade have much more time during the
school day to do other things than study
and still it's a city in a classroom and
the other thing of course is you were
asking about it is there another way is
that you get you could you could have
much slider way of employing those
standardized tests and and and control
systems on your schools that you have
right now that's what I've learned my
during our time here Eddy what do you
think I really sympathize with this as
well I read you 12 was a tough time for
me there's a lot of a lot of family
stuff going on my mom was really sick
and just you add on to that it's
incredible amount of stress and I I
think there is a better way I think
about for example when we if you ask
someone are you know you play you play
the violin that's amazing you know
you're an eighth grade violinist how old
is an eighth grade violinist and the
answer is they're they're 12 or 33 or 70
and the answer is whenever they are
ready for that
we'll go ahead and let it and I learned
mathematics in a way that sort of we
have this conveyor belt unfortunately
it's not just mathematics in fact it's
all of the curricular around Australia
we said okay it's time to move on from
this you know I'm afraid to ask this but
Elizabeth do you study mathematics it's
totally fine
once upon a time in United in 10 you had
to do maths you probably learned about
these things you know trigonometry sine
cos and tan
somewhere in your deep repressed memory
all of you have that bear and the thing
was you know that's that's getting it
something very simple about how
positions relate to each other but most
people probably learnt are sine of this
angle gives this number and then before
you could pause and understand what that
really represented you got tested on it
and there was time to move on and
unfortunately I think it's that that
very industrialized model toward
learning which does treat everyone much
like you know oh you're 15 years old
it's time for you to learn calculus I
think that that's a real
misrepresentation of what students are
they're human beings not machines in a
factory and I think that it's true we
have to be able to break a few things to
be able to get to that system because
we're not going to get there through
evolution it's going to take something
more dramatic than that Cindy just give
us a kind of picture of what it's like
in your school when you see your
students facing these kind of stresses
with the HSC coming up oh look my heart
breaks I mean you know the first thing I
probably say is I'm glad I'm not a
student now because things are a little
bit different back in my day and I think
you know we need to actually you know go
back to trusting the profession and
trusting in the professionalism of
teachers and how they and how they teach
kids and and where how where they teach
it rather than standardized testing okay
let's move on because got another
question I said we'd go to NAPLAN we got
a question on that from Megan O'Grady hi
both primary schools and high schools
are becoming more like marketplaces and
less like education institutions with
NAPLAN and hey Ches see results as the
most valuable assets as opposed to
student learning and well-being could
this be the reason for the poor results
that we're seeing in schools and could
better results be achieved through a
focus of student engagement and
personal achievement Jennifer I'll start
with you
linking NAPLAN with you know as a cause
of poor results doesn't really make a
lot of sense to me it's sort of like
blaming the x-ray for the fracture the
now plan puts a bit of a spotlight on
what what the level of performance isn't
it's only engagement as you know it's
only one day of reading and it's only
every two years and it's a snapshot at
that point in time of where a school is
going progressing you know where the
students in a school are progressing
with their learning and it's just
providing information that wasn't there
before
so before NAPLAN we didn't have any kind
of data about progress of students in
the key areas of the curriculum so in
literacy and numeracy so we had to if
you're a parent deciding whether or not
a particular school is the right school
for your child you were relying on
reputation word-of-mouth whether or not
the school uniforms were nice whether
the school grounds were nice what you'd
heard from other parents there wasn't
that extra element of information and I
think in terms of the idea that NAPLAN
is sort of creating a marketplace I've
not really seen any evidence of that the
studies that I have seen have shown that
parents have no plan as one of the
things that they look at but they they
look at other things and rate other
things more highly so I think no plan I
think it's useful but I think it has to
be kept in perspective gabi well I have
very serious concerns about NAPLAN and
they again speak to that idea that I've
raised about the standardization of
Education and I'm really actually quite
tired of hearing about how NAPLAN is
just a snapshot and it's just a couple
of days and it's just this and it's just
that putting the word just before these
things doesn't absolve NAPLAN of the
impact that it's having on our students
so Alyssa's question earlier or her
comments you know Alyssa's of the
generation now she would have been doing
that plan right for year three all the
way through and what we're seeing now
are our students are disengaged they're
disheartened
you know they're not they're not excited
to come to school they're not enthused
about their learning and this is the
effect that Knapp plants have what about
the effect on teachers teaching special
well I mean effect your teaching for
example look it's offensive to me to
hear that you know before NAPLAN we
didn't have any data we did we have
teachers you go in and you're not on it
you know as a teacher I do incredibly
important work I engage with these
students and I follow them step by step
through this learning and I can tell you
at the end of the day albeit that I will
be exhausted but I can tell you what
that child can read now and what new
gains they made with their writing and
where they're up to with their maths I
am human as instrument Assessor and
that's important that is valuable and
all of this you know will throw out the
NAPLAN test and then we'll you know
we'll get this result
you know saying that it's like blaming
the x-ray for the bone being broken the
bones not broken we have teachers there
and they have important skills they have
important understandings about
assessment and we need to value them
because we are losing that and it's a
great great tragedy brief answer on this
one but we can hear your frustration
here's who I'm ranting you're telling us
what you think and actually it's
important because this seems to be why
you left teaching profession you loved
yeah yeah I did because in the end I
felt that I wasn't being valued and if I
could just are you told me to be brief
I'll say it really quick at the end of
my teaching career I thought I was burnt
out I thought that's what had happened
to me
but I've since done a whole bunch of
reading and a whole bunch of research on
this and I realized that I wasn't burnt
out I was suffering the effects of
demoralization and what demoralization
is
it's different to burnout but it has
similar symptoms because burnout
suggests that I didn't manage my
resources well enough that I didn't take
care of myself well enough that I didn't
get my assessments done on time that I
should have done a bit more yoga and
maybe eaten some more vegetables right
demoralization is something very very
different demoralization is this idea
where you as a professional know very
very clearly what is best for your
students and the direction you should
take them in and you are told again and
again to go in another direction and
that is demoralizing I'm sorry I'm going
to get upset now but that is
demoralizing for me as a professional
for someone who brings herself to the
classroom and to the work and to those
children every day so I think we need to
start having a very serious think about
and conversation about NAPLAN and the
impact that it's having and more broadly
that idea of standardization I'll see ya
Jennifer I know you want to come in and
sort of hear from Parsi first and I
guess I want to hear if you don't have
this kind of standardized testing in
Finland what do you think how do you
think your teachers would respond to it
if it were introduced in the same way as
what we're hearing or will they accept
that you need to have a gauge of how
well schools and teachers are going and
how well students are measuring up
against some standards no I I think that
the teachers response certainly would be
a strike or something is something
similar but and and the response exactly
as you said Kathy that the the teachers
in Finland would say that we know we
have a way to report to the parents how
your children are doing by the way I
think it's a very fair question me as a
parent or anybody else here we want to
know how our children are doing but my
view is and and I say this with many
most of the teachers in Finland is that
we don't need a standardized testing
system like not plan for that we have to
keep in mind that standardized tests
like NAPLAN is created for one purpose
and one purpose only and we should not
use it for any other purposes for
example ranking or creating schools and
if the question here is that I often
hear when I travel around this beautiful
country my new home people are saying
that which we should we should pause
here just this is you
first day this was an Australian
resident so you're one of us I'm one of
you you know if the question is and
again this is a very fair question if
you if you're a taxpayer as I will be in
this country as well many of many of you
I think it's a fair question to ask that
how are these the school system how the
kids are learning but the response is
not necessarily a kind of a NAPLAN type
of analysis that is testing all the
children all the time it's just like
your if you go to do your medical check
and most of you do it every year when
you go to see the clinic and your doctor
see oh he doesn't suck all the blood out
of your party right let us take the text
sample to tell you whether you are in a
good health or not and we can do exactly
the same thing if the question is that
how healthy is our education system and
the the standardized testing data like
NAPLAN should not be used for any other
purposes for example helping parents to
select or choose the school for the
children that's right that's not the way
I wonder if on the other side that
Jennifer wants to respond to this and go
ahead yeah I just a couple of things
from the perspective of a researcher
NAPLAN data is incredibly useful because
we know more now about whether or not
policies have been effective we can see
trends that we couldn't see before so
that that's sort of at the macro level
also from you know from the parent
perspective I hear from a lot of parents
who say that they didn't have any
indication that their child might be
struggling with other literacy on you
mercy until they got their NAPLAN
results they've been told that that
their child was was doing fine that they
catch up that everything was okay but
NAPLAN provided and the information in
that which was you know it is
standardized standardizes in a dirty
word it just means that it's pegged
against a benchmark that allows you to
make some sort of assessment of whether
or not that child is or whether where
they fit on the range of achievement so
Jennifer I'm gonna pass over to the side
because I want to hear from Cindy and
NAPLAN has a an interesting history in
New South Wales and a lot of indigenous
kids in fact the statistics were
startling in the past year had to go
back and resit then Atlanta says 87% of
them I think in this state have to resit
NAPLAN tests in order to go on and do
the HSC now tell us the impact of that
well actually I'm not a fan in that
plane to be honest but but one of the it
is just this moment and a snapshot of a
moment in time and I think it's it's
written through the dominant it's
written through the cultural lens of the
dominant Society which I think
disadvantages Aboriginal kids and
there's there's a whole it's not just as
simple as you know our history of
accessing schooling hasn't been great
over the last you know thirty years and
that will take a while for the policies
and practices to actually go I mean you
know it's been in my time that we were
excluded from school so it's it's not
that far you think the testing is
actually unfair to indigenous can I use
of the cultural well from the cultural
lens of which they are and I think it
disadvantages as them and I don't think
there's enough support put in place to
actually support Aboriginal kids in
achieving literacy and numeracy
benchmarks Eddy can that plan all I want
to add you want benchmarks for
mathematics you want to know how well
your students are doing okay so I come
back to this original question and think
about like I think there is an easy
narrative to buy into which is that it's
it's really doom and gloom and I think
as the as the one incumbent teacher on
the panel I think I have a real
responsibility to say there is great
work happening in schools that are not
treating it as yeah it's this is you
know my school we buy a thousand pencils
that's our nap plan preparation you know
and we've got it we're ready we use it
as a as a data point but I think what's
really dangerous here like I as a
mathematician I love data statistics is
really really useful but data has a dark
side doctor is not a moral I think we'd
like to believe that it is we've
accepted that that kind of web but it's
it's it's not I'm dealing
the educational researcher talks a lot
about the value of feedback and how
important it is to give verbal feedback
and not just numerical feedback but to
me one most amazing things is when you
give students numerical feedback and
verbal feedback they behave almost just
like the people who got no verbal
feedback at all because numbers have
power you look at I it's heartbreaking
whenever it's not just now playing you
know I'll have my year 12 students and
they've just gone through a set of exams
and the first question they ask you is
what was the test ad off so I can work
out what 50% was and then they can work
out whether above or below this
arbitrary line because that number
speaks to them in a way they can't quite
express but it's super dangerous I think
we just have to recognize that these
tools often have a very good intent
behind them but they often have more
power than we intend let's move on
because we've as I said we've got a lot
of questions this one's from Vivian mr.
Sal Berg given that Finland has a
largely homogeneous population in terms
of race and religion and has less income
inequality than Australia do you think
that it is reasonable to model the
Australian education system after the
Finnish one in terms of culture and
economics that's it good
know you want to hear more no I think in
general it's a very dangerous idea to
try to imitate or model any education
system whether it's a Singapore or China
or Canada or whatever I think it's a
wrong way to think altogether I think
what Finland or other countries can
offer to Australia is a kind of an
interesting new space to think about all
these practices that you do for example
this new plan that we discussed just go
around the world and ask how different
countries like Finland or Canada do the
same thing that you do here through your
NAPLAN and you see different things that
leads to questions that why do you do
those things why don't you have the same
thing as we have here so that's the kind
of a right way to use the the countries
not to imitate or try to copy what the
other countries um let me just point out
one thing is actually you know I think
you would initially also asked about the
nature of the degree the master's degree
which is required for all teachers in
Finland
that's something that is hugely
distinguishes as the Australian and
finished models if you had to have a
master's degree to teach in this country
would that change things again Tony I
think it depends on what this master's
degree entails and they are different
they're a lot of studies actually the
show that the decree the level of decree
doesn't really make difference regarding
the students learning it makes a
difference doesn't it - how much you pay
your teachers in Finland and and also to
the degree of respect they have in this
it does but going back to the this
decree question for example if you have
primary school teachers like like
Finland has in some other countries or
kindergarten preschool teachers who have
studied four or five or six years
education and and all kinds of issues
related to children growing up of course
it makes a difference if you have
teachers who have not done that but but
if you have you may have as somebody who
holds a master's degree and teaching
mathematics but doesn't have necessarily
a math degree or math studies it doesn't
make any difference so I think when when
you look at Finland and other countries
with this question in mind you always
have to ask this question that what are
these people actually study what is what
is the primary school teacher in Finland
when she or he creates studied during
the five or six years and then ask this
question does this make any difference
when she or he is in a classroom I
presume you must have thought it made it
different so I wouldn't have had that is
part of absolutely yeah absolutely what
sort of difference does it make yeah and
not only better teachers if they bore
educated well not not necessarily better
teachers in terms of pedagogy and what
the teachers do but they you know one
important thing for teachers is there
kind of a self-esteem that in my country
we want to have teachers with a
self-esteem that they feel that they are
professionals just like medical doctors
and lawyers and and others and if you
don't have the same decree same level of
preparation for that it's very hard to
see we did we did slip back there to
save my country when this is your
you want me to start from high we can
talk about that you got my boy that will
come back to the aside will come back to
that token next question from Erin Kim
rich hi I'm a teacher who works in
disadvantaged schools the latest piece
of results tell us that inequality is
getting worse and the solution is
needs-based funding
despite this the government has
allocated 4.6 billion to the private and
Catholic sector essentially turning its
back on public education which houses
approximately 65 percent of the New
South Wales student population as a
teacher I see the impact of these
failing Wars the inequality of having to
share one book between to a lack of
computers and depleted student
motivation over summer in heat of 40
degree classrooms how do I keep my
students motivated to learn in the face
of these political decisions I'll start
with Cindy how do you keep your students
motivated to learn if there is inequity
in and they see it if they see very rich
and wealthy schools in the big cities
and then they see the the situation they
face how does it how hard is it that's a
really hard question hmm that's
exceptionally hard because I think you
know it's about to get kids motivated to
learn it's a it's it's a lot more than
resources to you know I think
governments of you know is focused on
money and focused on on what they can
but it's it's about what you do with the
money in the implementation of thinking
outside the box and the problem with the
system at the moment is that you know
people want to be innovative but they're
risk-averse and the government's a
risk-averse so they don't want to take
the risks of doing something different
which you could do if you actually had
resources to do it so I think you know
to to get kids motivated to learn it's
it's really it's it's a really difficult
question it's really about the teacher
and the school and the system then and
you know the support the system gives
and the ability to actually do things a
little bit different and innovative
especially in disadvantaged schools
Eddie let me ask you this because you
you went to a selective school in Sydney
you taught at that school subsequently
you now teach it a pretty well resource
school how does the inequity question
play on your mind
I place really strongly I mean I teach
in Northwest Sydney and it is a school
which while being very well resourced at
least until very recently we had a grand
total of 39 - mountable classrooms and
it's a struggle in sum up because this
is Australia and so it's really
important to recognize that no school is
exempt from that but at the same time
I've had the privilege of working across
New South Wales I was in the Riverina
earlier this year and it's just it's
frankly it's heartbreaking
I mean you mean no public school is
exempt from that because if you look at
the private schools with swimming pools
and sporting fields and air-conditioned
classrooms and very highly paid teachers
etc does that seem unfair to you those
two systems exist side-by-side to me
it's I what what's challenging most
about this is how complex and nuanced
this situation is I do think that it's
important for people to have some degree
of choice when it comes to the styling
of school that they go to I live fairly
close to a Montessori School and that's
a very different way of doing things not
sustainable australia-wide but if
parents are able to they have a
commitment or a conviction to do that I
think they should have the ability to
choose that but really I think the devil
ends up being in the details where are
those funds actually going to go and
what's it going to mean I mean for me I
know I shake my head when I look at a
federal level I hear the conversations
about funding doesn't make a difference
class sizes don't matter for me I
understand for example I can take a u12
extension to class and give me 60 kids
they'll just go to town but when I walk
into my year 10 class and there are kids
there with special needs with dyslexia
with hearing disabilities don't tell me
that it doesn't make a difference how
many teachers or SLS oh student learning
support officers you have in that
classroom funding makes a really big
difference but I think we're just not
need to be very careful not to make any
blanket statements oh yeah be I have
lots to say about this
I think that for a long time in
Australia we've been trying to offer the
champagne education on the beer budget
and we could always do with more funding
I think that you know when I hear this
expression that we we should have
needs-based funding which is you know
something that we hear in the media and
politicians saying as a teacher when I
hear that needs-based funding I know
that kid
I've taught that kid I've given
breakfast to that kid and we need to put
a face to these words that we bandy
about when we're talking about education
I think - I think that we need to get
really clear about the language that
we're using when we're talking about
this because I know that there are
plenty of Catholic schools out there in
regional and remote communities where
we're fundraising to raise money for
everything all the time it's not always
Kim Koppel Rose Bay that we should think
of when we hear about Catholic schools
the other thing is that I am so sick to
death of politicians using funding and
education as a political football every
time there's an election and just you
know because we'll have another one
won't we again and again and we'll be
you know so this needs to stop we need
to get clear about this because I can
tell you the story of the little boy who
needs that funding and we need to get
really serious about this again just
like I said with no plan it's that the
time has come we can't just keep you
know paddling along with this Jennifer
give us your perspective on needs-based
funding on the nature of the argument
we're having about or the national
discussion we're having about equity
well needs-based funding in the most
basic sense that children with greater
educational needs require a greater
level of resources in order to meet
those needs I think that's a you know an
essential concept and principle of any
kind of school funding system I was
pleased that that Gabby mentioned that
disadvantaged isn't confined to the
public
school sector that there are schools in
in the various school sectors that meet
those needs whether they're children
from disadvantaged backgrounds with
their children with special educational
needs and it's absolutely true that our
funding is not being targeted
sufficiently heavily towards the
children who need it the most so I think
that's got to be the focus rather than
thinking about what has someone else got
that I would like to have it's more
about making sure that everybody that
needs it has sufficient and that's where
the conversation needs to go yeah Pasi I
want to come to you on this because I
know you've someone's talking my ear at
that moment but I know you were we've
travelled around New South Wales with
Adrian piccoli when he was minister for
education here and you you actually
toured some of the most disadvantaged
schools what struck you most what when
you looked at it what do you think could
be fixed and how would you do it it's
exactly this thing that colleagues have
been talking about here that when I when
I see the schools where they are
obviously needs for children to get
support and help and different types of
programs those resources they're often
human resources but often also money
it's not available that's something that
in many other countries in the world
when I travel around I see exactly the
opposite that the resources and
investments are going to those
communities and and schools where there
are more needs in the children you know
there many things I still don't
understand in this my new country here
and and one of them is going back to
what Eddie was saying that the these
very same people who say that money
doesn't make any difference in education
then all of a sudden sign a four billion
dollar check for you know for those
schools actually already have a lot of
money money or resources so that's the
kind of it you know if you put Australia
into the big picture internationally one
thing that makes makes this education
system education systems here very
different is the way they are funded
that almost all the other OECD countries
are giving more money to those
communities and children where there are
more needs except Australia and that's
where you are very different this is not
only my opinion you can read what the
OECD and many others are saying even
more loudly than you can hear
right now I don't think that's quite we
definitely do have waiting fund funded
waiting towards children with greater
levels of need my point I think was that
that the targeting needs to be a more
efficient and more heavily towards that
that group of students at the moment
there is definitely that that targeted
funding though yeah but you know if I
look at the the research and statistics
about where the additional funding here
in Australia has gone for example since
2008 most of the additional funding has
gone to non-governmental schools and
these schools as we heard earlier only
cater about 15% of disadvantaged or
Aboriginal children I think it should be
the other way around that the the
additional money should go to those
schools and communities where they are
children who need more to be educated
better remembered he really doubtful
claims on few nights
sorry go briefly let us know on Twitter
and keep an eye on the RMIT ABC fact ik
and the conversation website for the
results the next question comes from
Sheila Daniel Daniel's Myers something
about Daniels mace our indigenous
invoice Tony Abbott says that school
attendance is the solution for improving
Aboriginal education outcomes there's no
evidence to support this position rather
we've got evidence to show that teacher
credibility confidence as well as
student engagement other drivers for
success so my question is how do we
develop a teaching workforce and a
schooling system that Aboriginal
students actually want to attend yes
Cindy we'll start with you obviously and
maybe you could start by do you agree
with that characterization of Tony
Abbott's Roth ah look you know I I was
told I couldn't swear on this
and as soon as they mentioned Tony yeah
but I thought I there's that was only
thing that came to mind as you know I
said he why's that because if you listen
to what he's saying he's claiming to
have a really cultured educated man like
you would do that I'm trying to just
talk to his well he claims it's sort of
passion for indigenous education and now
he's now he's got a be given a job by
the prime minister to try and do
something about it will you work with
him certainly if he wants to come over
to my place but you know I'd like you
know I'll just go back you know we were
we were extremely disappointed and
concerned when we actually and I've
heard this many times and I would agree
that you asked for a voice in Parliament
than government and you get pony not
Tony Jones I mean that would be a
privilege but you know Tony you know so
um yes so what can I say about him but
certainly you know for for Aboriginal
kids you know he find Tony Abbott
doesn't have I've just one question his
educational expertise and experience to
to actually make claims like he does I
think you know he's got the wrong end of
the stick when he talks about attendance
because if you look at kids in
Aboriginal kids in New South Wales when
a review was done not so long ago you
will find if you take out the chronic
non-attendance you'll find that at most
Aboriginal kids attend school most of
the time what they are is not engaged in
classrooms and I think you know we need
that's what we need it's the it's the
purpose of our stem camps that we run to
actually inspire kids to learn and
engage them through their culture I
think there needs to have a look at the
the quality of the teacher the quality
of the teaching and what curriculum we
actually use in um in in the country but
certainly you know we need to equip
teachers one it is true we do a lot of
professional learning and it is true
that the majority of the biggest thing
that comes out of is the lack of
confidence teachers have
in teaching aboriginal studies
Aboriginal perspectives and Aboriginal
content and I guess the more Aboriginal
people that are actually involved the
more Aboriginal you know more Aboriginal
role models the more Aboriginal people
are involved the more professional
learning we've done the more building up
of the cultural capability of the
workforce that can only actually be a
good thing and then Tony probably won't
have a job unless move obviously do have
still some very good questions to go to
Jennifer Sullivan has our next question
the accountability and paper work of
teaching increases every year our time
is constantly eaten up by analyzing data
documenting behavioral issues interviews
with parents photocopying work samples
collecting and annotating evidence
writing risk assessments the list goes
on despite these teachers have not been
provided extra time to complete these
tasks and this complete disregard for
the time required to provide quality
lessons and outcomes for students is
what is driving teachers from our
profession isn't it time that the
government reduces face-to-face teaching
and allows us to do our job properly
yeah we will start with you because you
have been driven from the profession
mm-hmm I think thanks for that Jennifer
and I'm sorry that you're suffering
through all that because it's just
arduous and in my opinion unnecessary I
think you know we talked earlier about
funding I actually think time is our
greatest commodity at the moment in
education and what teachers need is time
they need time to do all this work they
need time to think about their lessons
and plan and I think what's happening is
with all this standardization data
collection accountability documentation
it's taking us away from our core
purpose which is to teach our students
in front of us and you know I had
reached a point towards the end of my
teaching career where I was thinking if
the kids just stayed home today
I'd be able to get all my work done
that's crazy talk right I'm a teacher it
should be all about those children come
tell me did you find yourself doing and
I
no actually you did because I've read
books but you obviously found yourself
in situations where you were having to
do paperwork or assessments of
individual assessments while everyone
else went crazy in the classroom yeah I
mean is that a pretty typical sort of
scenario absolutely it's it's totally
typical teachers at the moment are just
going hand-to-mouth
you know they're just in survival mode
and they let me tell you they are
drowning not waiving this paperwork and
this administrivia is got it's driving
them out of the profession our attrition
rates are absolutely shocking those poor
new graduates who are coming in all
shiny eyed and ready to attend to their
vocation and in under five years they're
out the door you talk about funding and
wasting money and all that kind of stuff
well hello let's let's get these people
in there in the career that they've
chosen and help them to stay there I
think that you know we have really just
lost our way we're trying to run our
schools on a business model and schools
are not like anything else you can't say
they're like a business you can't say
they're like our hospitals you can't say
they're like anything else schools our
schools and they're really unique places
where if we're left to be the
professionals that we have trained to be
amazing things will happen magical
things will happen
extraordinary things will happen but at
the moment we've got too many people
trying to layer all these things on us
to tell us how to do our job and it's
crippling it's debilitating for for all
our teachers okay let me hear from Eddie
because you still remain bright-eyed as
far as like it's
how have you managed that and is this
there's a story not ring true to you or
this story as a head teacher of four
plus years definitely rings true to me
risk assessments reading 350 report
comments of a weekend this is just this
is life in a school I think for me what
is the most important thing to say what
they're to I think number one all these
things
I'm very earrin not to lose the baby
with the bathwater I think all of these
structures are great servants and
terrible masters and the problem is when
we we miss and we miss their purpose or
they they get in the driver's seat
and end up telling us as professionals
what our job is and how to do it
effectively I think that's a complete
reversal of the way things should be but
when I think about what why why is this
here well I I I was heartbroken when I
heard about it was late last year there
was a school and it was teaching the
wrong mathematics course to its students
and we don't want that to happen now the
problem it like what this is a bigger
problem why why do we live in a society
that's run by compliance and regulations
that we have to tick boxes too it's
because of this much bigger problem that
the teacher workforce has been driven to
and has been I mean I know in that
school I've been to that area there was
no mathematics head teacher in that
school that's why they didn't know that
it was it's easy to get confused my
principal still gets confused about
which one of those courses are which and
so there's a real Gorger respect with
respect it's okay he knows now I think
for me this is a symptom rather than a
cause and we need to get at why do we
have the system in the first place why
is it that bureaucrats find themselves
and they unable to trust the profession
that's where we have to attack the
policy does this sound familiar to you
yes it does and this is really what you
describe is an international thing
practically everywhere and I think it's
just a illustrate it's a kind of a
problem that we have had in around the
world really that when the authorities
are asking or insisting schools to do
something more that they forget to take
something away out at the same time and
now when we are considering the Gonski
2.0 and what does it mean for our
schools in the
which i think is very very important to
every time a new thing is coming into
the school in the lives of teachers and
principals that something else has to go
out I'm gonna move on to our next
question because we'd still like to get
through a few more Matthew sly hi I'm in
the first year of a master's degree in
secondary teaching in maths and science
and despite what the panel have been
saying despite what the panel have been
saying I'm looking forward to pursuing a
long career in teaching however news and
my own recent experience on prac has let
me debri believe that children and
society at large and parents don't
respect teachers as they should what can
be done to improve the respect and
standing for teachers in okay I have to
keep our answers a bit brief Gabby we'll
start with you I think I think we have
to start Remo lysing our teachers
because that's what they're feeling
that's what that's what they're
experiencing I've been fixing up their
morale
yeah yep I do and I think that needs to
come from how we speak about our
teachers I would like to see parents not
looking at schools as though they are
consumers and as though they're the
customer and the customer's always right
I don't like feeling that I'm threatened
by some decision I made in the classroom
using my professional judgment and then
being called to account on that I think
so I think there's a lot of language
that needs to happen around that a lot
of talking that needs to happen around
that about how we speak about our
teachers and how we talk about them and
how we address them and you know this
idea that parents can just sort of walk
in at the end of a school day you know
I'm a professional I'd love feet I'd
love to talk to you as a parent I'd love
for you to make an appointment so we can
have that time together and I can sit
down and properly address your concerns
so I think language and and the way
we're talking about things would be a
really good start and on that note I'd
love to have teachers instead of saying
I'm feeling stressed and burnt out I'd
love to hear teachers saying I am
feeling demoralized because then we're
starting to shift it's this discussion
to being about the system that we're in
not us not managing our resources
Jennifer let me let me ask you first of
all do you see a kind of decline in
respect for teachers in the general
public so and I'll also get you two to
talk to that point the Gabby is made
about schools being very different not
being something that you can put
economic models around as if they're a
business sure I don't think that it's
across the board that there's a decline
in the status and respect for teaching
as a profession I think no you don't
think that I don't I think that many
parents have a good relationship and
respect for their own child's teachers
what we see is it's a strange phenomenon
when you look at surveys about how
people feel about the country's
education system that most parents are
quite happy with their child's teacher
in their child's school but they have
quite a dim view of education across the
board and so it's a strange phenomenon
that you see in that respect having said
that I think that there needs to be also
some acknowledgement that not all
teachers are fantastic there is a range
and some are wonderful and some are you
know they're doing a good job but
they're not you know not necessarily
inspiring and that's the same in every
profession and there's a tendency to
ignore that fact that yes one year your
child might have a teacher that they're
ok the next year they might have one
that's fantastic and I think it's
important to be honest about and about
that I add to that that I I agree with
you there and I think that you know one
of the first things you learn when you
go to study to become a teacher is that
the students in front of you are not
empty vessels you know they come with
all their cultural capital and I think
we need to acknowledge too that teachers
who go into this as a vocation then are
empty vessels either good teachers are
bringing themselves into their workplace
as well and sometimes you know a
teachers having a bad day or you know
there's pressures at home and because of
the nature of the work we do which is to
give of ourselves that impacts as well
so I agree with you that we need to
accept that sometimes not all teachers
are performing at
you know maximum you know standard
because we're human okay Eddie I want to
get your perspective on this because you
may have a very different view given
that you know there are millions of
people watching your YouTube versions of
your classes that you travel around
speak to packed houses in rural areas of
Australia I mean do you sense at all
this idea there's been a decline in
respect for teachers I think it's really
difficult to take a cultural pulse of an
entire country I think there's a real
disparate sort of the range of different
attitudes toward teaching I can still
think back to when I was in you 12 and
my own teachers found out that I was
going into education and from an
academically selective high school that
was just Lord a thing that was dying I
was just kind of that's really funny
what are you really doing so so I think
that I still remember that and I still
remember you know the the the thoughts
and conversations that I have with
parents at my school of those kids and
and the you know I taught the school
cats in a couple of years ago who is now
becoming a mathematics teacher which is
so exciting for me but also I know I
mean I think your question is very
personal in that you know what what is
the thing that you can do two things
number one you need to guard that hope
you're a teacher that's your job I go
into this I remember in my first year
teaching a a particular class and they
were in in mathematics we call it a you
10 five point one class they've been
going through ten years of mathematics
where they just don't get it and they're
probably there mainly because of the
minimum school-leaving age and sometime
in term two halfway through they said to
me so you you're still here
you're still trying to teach us they had
gotten used to people giving up on them
and I said you know when that bill goes
I have to stop the class we're pretty
close I get it I get it you're a
professional not giver-upper ah that's
that's the technical term so I think
there's that but there's also a hundred
thousand conversations they're going to
happen tomorrow between teachers between
parents and children about what do we
think about schooling and it's in those
conversations that's the way our culture
forms our view of Education
that's where the difference we made okay
and some of those conversations we've
been having here with very eloquent
teachers and educators but that is all
we have time for tonight please thank
our panel Parsi Selberg Jennifer
Buckingham Gabi Stroud Eddie Wu and
Cindy Berwick
thank you very much I'm Tony Jones
here's a bonus question we couldn't fit
on Q&A is from Ally Clark their race to
gain entry into opportunity classes and
selective schools is seeing ten-year-old
studying through their holidays and
anxiety levels at concerning lis high
levels on top of this their schools are
increasingly being filled by the rich
and they're concentrated in wealthy
metropolitan areas our selective schools
just widening gaps between rich and poor
the country and the city and creating
mental health problems in our youth
Gabby you start with you what do you
think of selective schools the notion of
them high what do you think about the
fact that as the questioner is
suggesting that you've got kids going to
tutors and at a fairly young age working
their butts off to try and get into them
yeah yes look I agree that does widen
the gap and I think there are lots of
things that are widening the gap you
know I think that we're not not
acknowledging the need for a better
curriculum that serves the needs of our
indigenous students that widens the gap
you know any any time we do something in
education it's not good enough just to
say what's working we need to think
about under what conditions does this
work and I think that's probably the
question we need to ask around that
because you know to have ten year olds
that are cramming to get into a school
is that's a tragedy that's not what
learning is about we've missed the mark
Jennifer what do you think I think if
you've got a child who needs to spend
their whole holidays cramming or if it's
elective entry into a selective high
school and that's really setting a very
very huge kind of huge burden for them
throughout the rest of their schooling
if they need to do that to be accepted
or to gain a place in one of those
schools and that's the way they're going
to have to continue throughout their
whole schooling and I think that's a
really tough call
and so while selective schools I think
you know they can they do serve a
purpose I think that it is helpful for
children who
academically gifted to be educated with
other children who are also academically
gifted but I think you know something
Eddie said earlier was that sometimes
those good intentions can become skewed
and the race to get into those schools
just takes on a whole new level of
stress and it's an unintended
consequence of policy this is pretty
much a New South Wales phenomena but you
do live here what do they do this in
Finland do they have selective schools
nope and I just have four words for you
let the children play
[Applause]
there's a song that goes along me that I
let make you singing what do you think
Sydney I look I'm not a fan of selective
schools I'll make sure you think you
know I'm just strong believer in
comprehensive high schools there's a
whole lot of research out there that
supports you know different of differing
abilities of kids and and what it does
to support their learning so you know
I'm all for comprehensive high schools
but does that mean there's an argument
as to whether selective schools are in
fact a kind of educational apartheid
what do you think definitely
yeah absolutely you know cuz I'm you
know like a comprehensive school it
doesn't matter you know like as teachers
in a profession you know we've got to
differentiate learning you know and
that's that's what we do and if you know
we've got a range of abilities in our
classrooms then then we need to to to
cater for each of those needs and that's
what a teacher's taught and that's why
we go into the profession we don't need
selective high schools to cream off a
top row who think they possibly better
than us Eddy economic line was a
headline in The Sydney Morning Herald
doing a whole series on selective high
schools and you went to one did you feel
like you're being creamed off and chosen
it you feel like one of the chosen
people when you were there let's put it
that way I don't think I've ever felt
like I've been creamed off but I'm just
- thanks Ali for your question um I I
think for me okay catch it in these
terms so forties Kramer went to a
selective high school taught at one for
many years we as a country we love sport
which kind of it's one of our
characteristic qualities we believe in
identifying elite sports men in sports
women my kids play soccer on a Saturday
morning and they're not elite material
but I think there is a place for both I
I resist the dichotomy that it's just we
do it and and it's going to be you know
we we it's an economic situation that
people are going to go if it's something
that they are going to fight for if they
know they can get better outcomes
academic or social or otherwise or we
just turf the system um every system is
a con
- everyone for me in some way I can't
answer this question clearly because I
am Who I am in many ways for better and
for worse because of having inhabited
that system so I'm completely biased all
I can speak to is what I gained from
that the difficulties that I've
absolutely seen I'll never forget
watching the ambulance go out of my
school because a girl had taken just
before an exam a whole packet of
neurofen because she was about to go
into an exam and she saw no other way
because of that pressure that she spoke
off that's real that's awful vero there
are more things complex at play than
just we do selective scores on not well
maybe one way or the other you've
obviously given back a great deal and
you continue to do so so we thank you
for that and that's all we have time for
so please thank also our questioner ally
Clark
[Applause]